science
the very word for many of you conjures
unhappy memories of boredom in high
school biology or physics class but let
me assure you that what you did there
had very little to do with science that
was really though
what of science it was the history of
what other people had discovered what
I'm most interested in as a scientist is
the how of science because science is
knowledge in process we make an
observation guess an explanation to that
observation and then make a prediction
that we can test with an experiment or
other observation a couple of examples
first of all people notice that the
earth was below the sky above and both
the Sun and the moon seemed to go around
them their guest explanation was that
the earth must be the center of the
universe the prediction everything
should circle around the earth this was
first really tested when Galileo got his
hands on one of the first telescopes and
as he gazed into the night sky what he
found there was a planet Jupiter with
four moons circling around it he then
used those moons to follow the path of
Jupiter and found that Jupiter also was
not going around the earth but around
the Sun so the prediction test failed
and this led to the discarding of the
theory that the earth was the center of
the universe
another example Sir Isaac Newton noticed
that things fall to the earth the guest
explanation was gravity the prediction
that everything should fall to the earth
but of course not everything does fall
to the earth so do be discard gravity no
we revised the theory and said gravity
pulls things to the earth unless there's
an equal and opposite force in the other
direction this led us to learn something
new
we began to pay more attention to the
bird and the bird's wings and just think
of all the discoveries that have flown
from that line of thinking so the test
failures the exceptions the outliers
teach us what we don't know and lead us
to something new this is how science
moves forward this is how science learns
sometimes in the media and even more
rarely but sometimes even scientists
will say that something or other has
been scientifically proven but I hope
that you understand that science never
proves anything definitively forever
hopefully science remains curious enough
to look for and humble enough to
recognize when we have found the next
outlier the next exception which like
Jupiter's moons teaches us what we don't
actually know we're going to change
gears here for a second the caduceus for
the symbol of Medicine means a lot of
different things to different people but
most of our public discourse on medicine
really turns it into an engineering
problem we have the hallways of Congress
and the boardrooms of insurance
companies that try to figure out how to
pay for it
the Ephesus and epidemiologists try to
figure out how best to distribute
medicine and the hospitals and
physicians are absolutely obsessed with
their protocols and checklists trying to
figure out how best to safely apply
medicine these are all good things
however they also all assume at some
level that the textbook of medicine is
closed we start to measure the quality
of our health care by how quickly we can
access it doesn't surprise me that in
this climate many of our institutions
for the provision of health care start
to look a heck of a lot like Jiffy Lube
the only problem is that when I
graduated from medical school I didn't
get one of those little doohickeys that
your mechanic has to plug in your car
and find out exactly what's wrong with
it because the textbook of medicine is
not closed medicine is science medicine
is knowledge in process we make an
observation we guess an explanation of
that observation and then we make a
prediction that we can test now the
testing ground of most predictions in
medicine is populations and you may
remember from those boring days in
biology class that populations tend to
distribute around a mean as a Gaussian
or a normal curve therefore in medicine
after we make a prediction from a guest
explanation we test it in a population
that means that what we know in medicine
our knowledge and our know-how comes
from populations but extends only as far
as the next outlier the next exception
which like Jupiter's moons will teach us
what we don't actually know now I am a
surgeon who looks after patients with
sarcoma sarcoma is a very rare form of
cancer it's the cancer of flesh and
bones and I would tell you that every
one of my patients is an outlier is an
exception there is no surgery I have
ever performed for a sarcoma patient
that has ever been guided by a
randomized controlled clinical trial
what we consider the best kind of
population-based evidence in medicine
people talk about thinking outside the
box but we don't have a box in sarcoma
what we do have as we take a bath in the
uncertainty and unknowns and exceptions
and outliers that surround us in sarcoma
is easy access to what I think are those
two most important values for any
science humility and curiosity because
if I am humble and curious when a
patient asks me a question and I don't
know the answer I'll ask a colleague who
may have a similar albeit distinct
patient with sarcoma we'll even
established international collaborations
those
patience we'll start to talk to each
other through chat rooms and support
groups it's through this kind of humbly
curious communication that we begin to
try and learn new things as an example
this is a patient of mine who had a
cancer near his knee because of humbly
curious communication in international
collaborations we have learned that we
can repurpose the ankle to serve as the
knee when we have to remove the knee
with a cancer he can then wear a
prosthetic and run and jump and play
this opportunity was available to him
because of international collaborations
it was desirable to him because he had
contacted other patients who had
experienced it and so exceptions and
outliers in medicine teach us what we
don't know but also lead us to new
thinking now very importantly all the
new thinking that outliers and
exceptions lead us to in medicine does
not only apply to the outliers and
exceptions it is not that we only learn
from sarcoma patients ways to manage
sarcoma patients sometimes the outliers
and the exceptions teach us things that
matter quite a lot to the general
population like a tree standing outside
of forests the outliers and the
exceptions draw our attention and lead
us into a much greater sense of perhaps
what a tree is
we often talk about losing the forest
for the trees but one also loses a tree
within a forest but the tree that stands
out by itself makes those relationships
that define a tree the relationships
between trunk and roots and branches
much more apparent even if that tree is
crooked or even if that tree has very
unusual relationships between trunk and
roots and branches it nonetheless draws
our attention and allows us to make
observations that we can then test in
the general population I told you that
sarcomas are rare they make up about 1%
of all cancers you also probably know
that cancer is considered a genetic
disease by genetic disease we mean that
cancer is caused by oncogenes that are
turned on
cancer and tumor suppressor genes that
are turned off to cause cancer you might
think that we learned about oncogenes
and tumor suppressor genes from common
cancers like breast cancer and prostate
cancer and lung cancer but you'd be
wrong we learned about oncogenes and
tumor suppressor genes for the first
time and that anybody little 1% of
cancers called sarcoma in 1966 Peyton
Roo got the Nobel Prize for realizing
that chickens had a transmissible form
of sarcoma 30 years later Harold Varmus
and Mike Bishop discovered what that
transmissible element was it was a virus
carrying a gene the SARC uncle gene now
I will not tell you that Sark is the
most important oncogene I will not tell
you that Sark is the most frequently
turned on uncle gene and all of cancer
but it was the first uncle gene the
exception the outlier drew our attention
and led us to something that taught us
very important things about the rest of
biology now AP 53 is the most important
tumor suppressor gene it is the most
frequently turned off to respess seen in
almost every kind of cancer but we
didn't learn about it from common
cancers we learned about it when doctors
Lee and from a knee were looking at
families and they realized that these
families had way too many sarcomas I
told you that sir coma is rare remember
that a one-in-a-million diagnosis if it
happens twice in one family is way too
common in that family the very fact that
these are rare draws our attention and
leads us to new kinds of thinking now
many of you may say and may rightly say
that yeah Kevin that's great but you're
not talking about a bird's wing you're
not talking about moons floating around
some planet Jupiter this is a person
this outlier this exception may lead to
the advancement of science but this is a
person and all I can say is that I know
that all too well I have conversations
with these patients with rare and deadly
diseases
I write about these conversations these
conversations are terribly fraught
they're fraught with horrible phrases
like I have bad news or there's nothing
more we can do
sometimes these conversations turn on a
single word terminal silence can also be
rather uncomfortable where the blanks
are in medicine can be just as important
as the words that we use in these
conversations what are the unknowns what
are the experiments that are being done
did this little exercise with me if you
see up there on the screen you see this
phrase nowhere
notice where the blank is if we move
that blank one space over nowhere
becomes now here the exact opposite
meaning just by shifting the blank one
space over I'll never forget the night
that I walked into one of my patients
rooms I had been operating long that day
but I still wanted to come and see him
he was a boy I had diagnosed with bone
cancer a few days before he and his
mother had been meeting with the
chemotherapy doctors earlier that day
and he had been admitted to the hospital
to begin chemotherapy it was almost
midnight when I got to his room he was
asleep but I found his mother reading by
flashlight next to his bed she came out
in the hall to chat with me for a few
minutes turned out that what she had
been reading was the protocol that the
chemotherapy doctors had given her that
day she had memorized it she said dr.
Jones you told me that we don't always
win with this type of cancer but I've
been studying this protocol and I think
I can do it
I think I can comply with these very
difficult treatments I'm gonna quit my
job I'm gonna move in with my parents
I'm gonna keep my baby safe I didn't
tell her I didn't stop to correct her
thinking she was trusting in a protocol
that even with come even if complied
with
wouldn't necessarily save her son I
didn't tell her I didn't fill in that
blank but a year and a half later her
boy nonetheless died of his cancer
should I have told her and many of you
may say so what I don't have sarcoma
known in my family has sarcoma and this
is all fine and well but it probably
doesn't matter in my life and you're
probably right
sarcoma may not matter a whole lot in
your life but where the blanks are in
medicine does matter in your life I
didn't tell you one dirty little secret
I told you that in medicine we test
predictions in populations but I didn't
tell you and so often medicine never
tells you that every time an individual
encounters medicine even if that
individual is firmly embedded in the
general population
neither the individual nor the physician
knows where and that population the
individual will land therefore every
encounter with medicine is an experiment
you will be a subject in an experiment
and the outcome will be either a better
or a worse result for you as long as
medicine works well we're fine with fast
service bravado brimming ly confident
conversations but when things don't work
well sometimes we want something
different a colleague of mine removed a
tumor from a patient's limb he was
concerned about this tumor in our
physician conferences he talked about
his concern that this was a type of
tumor that had a high risk for coming
back in the same limb but his
conversations with the patient or
exactly what a patient might want
brimming with confidence he said I got
it all and you're good to go
she and her husband were thrilled they
went out celebrated fancy dinner opened
a bottle of champagne the only problem
was a few weeks later she started to
notice another nodule in the same area
turned out he hadn't gotten at all and
she was
good to go but what happened at this
juncture absolutely fascinates me my
colleague came to me and said Kevin
would you mind looking after this
patient for me I said why you know the
right thing to do as well as I do you
haven't done anything wrong
he said please just look after this
patient for me he was embarrassed not by
what he had done but by the conversation
that he had had by the overconfidence
so I performed a much more invasive
surgery and had a very different
conversation with the patient afterwards
I said most likely I've gotten it all
and you're most likely good to go but
this is the experiment that we're doing
this is what you're going to watch for
this is what I'm going to watch for and
we're going to work together to find out
if this surgery will work to get rid of
your cancer I guarantee you she and her
husband did not crack another bottle of
champagne after talking to me but she
was now a scientist not only a subject
in her experiment and so I encourage you
to seek humility and curiosity in your
physicians almost 20 billion times each
year a person walks into a doctor's
office and that person becomes a patient
you or someone you love will be that
patient sometime very soon
how will you talk to your doctors what
will you tell them what will they tell
you they cannot tell you what they do
not know but they can tell you when they
don't know if only you'll ask so please
join the conversation thank you
[Applause]